[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
c'est sens public votre rendez-vous de
débat de chronique et de reportage sur
Public Sénat on est ensemble tous les
jours du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos experts et voici le sommaire de ce
10 janvier combien de ministres quel
équilibre droite gauche des
personnalités LR vont-ils l'intégrer la
formation du premier prier gouvernement
à tal va prendre plusieurs jours
permettra-t-elle au nouveau locatair de
Matignon de regagner des marges de
manœuvre au Parlement on en débat dans
une minute et puis pour notre second
thème on plonge dans la poudrière
libanaise l'un des chefs militaire du
Hezbollah été tué hier par une frappe
israélienne dans le sud du pays une
semaine après la mort du numéro 2 du
ramas dans des condition similaire près
de la capitale Beyrouth la crainte d'une
extension du conflit
ré dans les jours à venir une grande
partie des discussions avec tous nos
alliés et partenaires portera sur les
mesures qu'ils peuvent prendre en
utilisant l'influence et les liens dont
ils disposent pour faire en sorte que ce
conflit ne s'étende
pas le Liban peut-il à son tour basculer
dans la guerre quel est le poids
politique et militaire du Hezbollah
cette organisation est-elle une
marionnette de l'Iran ne ratez pas les
explications la confrontation de nos
invités ce sera dans TR quart d'heure
mais d'abord donc le jour 2 du Premier
ministre Gabriel hatal et ce déplacement
symbolique politique aussi dans un
commissariat du valdoise Jonathan
duprieèz 2è déplacement de terrain en 24
he Gabriel hatal sature l'espace
médiatique après le Pas de Calais le
Premier ministre fraîchement nommé s'est
rendu dans un commissariat du valdoise
accompagné de Gérald de daran un
déplacement très politique du nouveau
locataire de Matignon auprès d'un
Ministre expérimenter et une manière
d'affirmer sa vision de l'autorité
d'entrée de jeu quand on parle de
sécurité quand on parle d'ordre c'est
évidemment la police ce sont les forces
de sécurité qui sont en première ligne
mais c'est toute la société qui doit
être mobilisée je ne conçois pas de
société sans ordre et sans règles si
certains voient en ce déplacement un
signe du maintien probable de Gérald
Darmanin à l'intérieur rien n'est moins
sûr pour le reste du casting
gouvernemental qui pourrait être annoncé
demain un poids lourd comme Bruno Lemer
à Bercy ou Sébastien le Cornu aux armées
sont pressentis pour rester mais rien ne
filtre sur la nouvelle équipe qui aura
la lourde tâche d'insuffler un nouvel
élan au second quinquena d'Emmanuel
Macron en panne Gabriel Atal ce C
attendu au tournant je souhaite vraiment
et sincèrement euh toutes ses chances
euh au nouveau Premier ministre j'y mets
j'allais dire trois objectifs d'abord de
regarder euh
dans les yeux la vérité de l'état du
pays état financier état de fracture
communautaire et il faut qu'il soit
attentif au territoire une partie de la
gauche promet elle aussi de ne rien
laisser passer au plus jeune premier
ministre de la 5e République la France
insoumise réclame à Gabriel hatal de se
soumettre à un vote de confiance à
l'Assemblée nationale si Monsieur hatal
refuse de se soumettre à un vote de
confiance nous le forcerons entre
guillemets à se soumettre à un vote de
confiance par le dépôt d'une motion de
censure si la France insoumise brandit
la menace de censurer le nouveau chef du
gouvernement pas sûr qu'une motion LFI
entraîne l'extrême droite dans son
sillage je pense pas que les Français
veulent qu'on ferme la porte à priori
qu'on censure à priori un gouvernement
qui n'a encore rien fait ou qui n'a
encore rien annoncé mais en fait je
pense que hatal va se révéler en fait un
premier ministre placebo si la
nomination de Gabriel hatal fait
l'événement le nouveau locataire de
Matignon n'a pas encore préciser sa
feuille de route si ce n'est la volonté
affichée d'aller
vite on décortique les premiers pas de
Gabriel Atal dans son nouveau costume de
Premier ministre avec Pascal Perino
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
politologue professeur à Sciences pour
Paris an Charline Bina bonsoir et
bienvenue
constitutionnaliste et maître de
conférence en droit public Stéphane
zumste bonsoir et bienvenueons vous êtes
directeur du département Opinion à
l'institut de sondage hipsos et Mathieu
croissand éctoraliste politique bonsoir
Mathieu bonsoir à tous bienvenue à vous
aussi un nouveau Premier ministre un
nouveau gouvernement Pascal Pino comment
est-ce vécu parler français est-ce que
c'est forcément un événement ou une
péripétie c'est entre les deux ça dépend
peut-être de la personnalité du c'est
entre les deux mais vous savez bon les
Français restent assez sceptique par
rapport au remanement au changement de
gouvernement et ils attendent pour voir
cependant quand on compare ce qui est
comparable on s'aperçoit que la
nomination de Gabriel hatal rencontre un
une certaine un effet de curiosité hein
un effet de curiosité euh plutôt positif
on entendait tout à l'heure le président
dans du Sénat l'accueil par Gérard
Larchet a été du même type j'allais dire
que l'accueil que lui font les Français
a priori euh il n'y a pas de de de rejet
et les Français considèrent que ça n'est
pas peut-être on le verra demain quand
on saura la composition du gouvernement
que ça n'est pas simplement j'allais
dire un effet de de de communication il
y a déjà eu d'ailleurs dans les
premières prises de parole de Gabriel
hatal des thèmes des axes dont on voit
bien que ils sont en phase avec les
attentes des Français quand ils parlent
en effet de l'école quand il parlent de
la sécurité quand il parle de
l'immigration quand il parle du travail
voilà ce sont des thèmes qui aux yeux
des Français restent des thème à
privilégier pour le chef de gouvernement
et pour un gouvernement an Bina ce
nouveau Premier ministre il a choisi un
commissariat on l'a vu hein comme alors
j'allais dire premier déplacement
thématique hier était dans le Pas de
Calais bon là c'était vraiment un un
choix assez symbolique et politique
est-ce que vous diriez qu'il fait d'une
pierre de coup c'estàd qu'à la fois il
parle effectivement au français sur des
thèmes importants et puis il marque à la
culotte un certain Gérald armanin
certainement on a oui dire que son
arrivée à Matignon n'était pas du goût
de certain dont ce Gérald daranin a
priori qu' a évidemment officiellement
démenti mais voilà on on est à l'aube
d'un nouveau gouvernement avec
évidemment toutes les tensions interne
que cela supposera parce que certains se
prétendent ténor làhaut d'autres ne le
sont pas dans ce gouvernement on a à
faire on l'a déjà dit mintes fois à un
Premier ministre qui est le plus jeune
de la 5e donc beaucoup de choses à
prouver finalement une tâche qui pour le
coup sera quand même sûrement un petit
peu moins tendancieuse et difficile que
celle d'Élisabeth borne puisque les
textes annoncés sont moins clivants que
l'immigration et les retraites mais euh
autant dire que en tant que Premier
ministre pour le moment il y a une
espèce de d'état de grâce parce que
voilà c'est une personnalité connue qui
plaît à l'opinion mais les preuves de
force c'est le Parlement c'est
l'Assemblée nationale et ça autant dire
que on est encore à l'aube de moment où
tout se passe bien euh vraiment la
confiance ça je pense qu'il n
sollicitera pas mais tout le reste va va
va devenir pour moi plus compliqué par
la suite alors justement pour puisqu'on
parle de confiance première code de
confiance cette fois-ci auprès des des
Français du Premier ministre hatal euh
question simple faites-vous confiance à
Gabriel hatal tant que Premier ministre
56 % de de réponses positives ce qu'il
place au-dessus d'un Édouard Philippe
quand il arrive en mai 2017 53 % mais
niveau que Jean Castex en juillet 2020
et bien au-dessus d'éisabeth borne en
mai 2022 Stéphane zums cette popularité
elle va forcément lui servir mais
pendant combien de temps ça dure
longtemps une popularité de Premier
ministre la question est la réponse est
compliquée mais I a priori non ça ne va
pas durer très très longtemps ce que
montre quand même ce chiffre c'est que
d'une part il faut quand même le
souligner ça faisait assez longtemps
qu'une décision du Président de la
République n'était pas approuvée par une
C majorité limitée mais par une majorité
des français donc ça on dit quand même
long sur ce choix et sur l'image très
très positif dont bénéficie pour
l'instant en tout cas Gabriel Atal qui
était quasiment inconnu en tout cas peu
connu jusqu'à sa nomination au poste de
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
ensuite a progressé de façon assez
spectaculaire pourquoi Pascal Pino en
parlait tout à l'heure parce que tout ce
qu' toutes ces prises de position
notamment sur l'autorité sur le port de
la BAA enfin sur toutes choses qui ont
été décliné sur le rétablissement de la
note des sanctions sur le la parole
donné le dernier mot donné au
professeurs et plus au parents en cas de
redoublement toutes choses qui vont dans
le sens de l' qui plais à une certaine
un certain segment de l'électorat on
fait que il a progressé de façon très
spectaculaire au point dans les codes de
popularité auprès au point pardon de
devenir l'une des personnalités les
préférées des Français en tout cas dans
la classe politique ça montre que il y a
un vrai effet un vrai moment à tal et
que les français pour l'instant lui
savent grer peut-être d'être au bon
poste au bon moment ça ne bénéficiera
pas à Emmanuel Macron en tout cas dans
l'immédia maintenant pour répondre à
votre question sur la durée de cet état
de gr gr pardon est-ce qu'il y aura un
état de grâ je ne sais pas mais les
choses compliquées commencent maintenant
évidemment il commen assez haut contenu
du contexte les choses vont se corser
d'autant plus qu'il aura toujours à
faaire à des
oppositions très mobilisé qui n'auront
de cess que de critiquer le gouvernement
mais Pascal est-ce que le matinon c'est
forcément une machine à fabriquer de de
l'impopularité pour un premier ministre
oui oui en effet on parle toujours de
l'enfer de matigon la tâche n'est jamais
facile quel que soit le le talent mais
est-ce que c'est toujours vrai avec le
quena parce que curur c'est quand même
pas mal déplacé vers l'Élysée oui de la
machine à à souci je vais dire ça
joliment oui c'est-à-dire que on
s'aperçoit dans les
quinquenas que le premier ministre ne
protège plus le le le le président de la
République et que l'impopularité touche
touche directement le président de la
République et que parfois on le verra
peut-être ça posera peut-être quelques
problème le Premier ministre s'en tire
mieux que le Président de la République
ce qui terme pourrait susciter quelques
conflit entre les deux têtes entre les
deux têtes de de
l'exécutif un Charl Bina on va parler de
ce premier chantier de Gabriel
c'estàdire la formation du gouvernement
on est en plein dedans là c'est là c'est
l'aire des rumeurs on a tous bon
j'imagine Mathieu vous avez le téléphone
qui a qui a sonné un certain nombre de
fois AC des noms improbables voilà je
vous demanderaiis pas de les citer parce
qu'ils sont improbables on rappelle
peut-être d'abord que Emmanuel Macron et
son premier ministre ils peuvent prendre
quoi tout le temps c'est pas c'est pas
écrit dans la
Constitution que ça doit durer 24h 72h
en effet il y a pas du tout de limite
temporel ni de limite de nom ni de
limite de composition vraiment c'est le
général de Gaulle qui avait une citation
assez intéressante sur la formation du
déjà du Premier ministre et du
gouvernement en disant on respecte
l'intérêt général pour les hommes et on
respecte la majorité quant au Parlement
donc en fait voilà on est dans un moment
à la fois politique et à la fois
personnalisé où il faut choisir les
bonnes personnes aux bons endroits ça
peut parfois tirer à l'avantage du
Premier ministre surtout dans les
périodes de cohabitation sinon là encore
une phrase du général de Gaulle le
Premier ministre donne son avis et c'est
moi qui donne la conclusion c'est un peu
comme ça que ça se passera sûrement la
seule deadline c'est qu'en fait on n pas
changé le calendrier parlementaire et
mardi il y a une séance de question au
gouvernement à l'Assemblée nationale
donc il faudra un gouvernement un
gouvernement mais les ministres qui
parce queon là on a vu Gérald armanin
qui était au au côté de de Gabriel Atal
tant qu'il y a pas eu de passation de
pouvoir il est toujours ministre de
l'Intérieur officiellement et c'est
écrit d'ailleurs dans le dans la
communiqué de presse de nomination de
Gabriel Atal ellisabeth borne gère
encore les affaires courantes
c'est-à-dire que fictivement ce
gouvernement dure c'est le principe de
continuité de l'État jusqu'à ce qu'un
nouveau soit nommé donc a priori Gérald
armanin dort encore ce soir ministre de
l'Intérieur la question est de savoir
s'il le sera demain dans le nouveau
gouvernement même s'il peut conserver
son poste sans problème mais c'est une
équation complexe d'abord parce qu'ils
ont promis une nouvelle fois ce fameux
gouvernement resserré alors on verra si
c'est un gouvernement de combat c'est
généralement l'autre tarte à la crème en
tout cas un gouvernement resserré c'est
quand même très compliqué à faire
d'autant qu' faut respecter la parité
que le premier ministre est un homme
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut plus de
femmes or il y a pas beaucoup de de
femmes qui ont une surface politique
médiatique forte dans le camp macroniste
en tout cas il faut ensuite respecter
les sensibilités politiques les alliés
que ce soit François Baou modem que ce
soit hdard Philippe et horizon et c'est
d'autant plus important que la majorité
est fragile d'autant plus
mais encore plus compliqué dans un
gouvernement et ilut pouve pas conserver
tout le monde faut quand même donner un
effet nouveauté qui vous sacrifiez et
puis faut que tout soit validé comme le
disait par le Président de la République
donc tout ça complexifie beaucoup
beaucoup l'équation ou la question de
l'équilibre droite gauche elle va
évidemment se poser et pour l'ancien
Premier ministre Jean-Pierre rafarin il
faut que des LR fassent partie de ce
gouvernement on écoute je pense que la
majorité aujourd'hui a besoin de
s'élargir pour pouir pass ses textes et
elle ne peut s'élargir aujourd'hui que
au centre et au centre droit donc vous
dites à des à des à vos amis de rentrez
au gouvernement si on vous le demande ah
je pense que les les LR qui vous savez
moi je les ai quitté quand ils ont pas
voulu choisir entre Le Pen et Macron
mais aujourd'hui pour ce qui me concerne
j'ai vraiment le sentiment que les LR
doivent être un parti de gouvernement
les dirigeants de LR ils ont aujourd'hui
60 ans à peu près et donc c'est
maintenant qu'il doivent s'afficher
comme un parti de gouvernement autrement
ils n'existeront pas dans les élections
ils seront marginaux comme ils l'ont été
ère présidentielle il faut évidemment
assumer les Français ils veulent des
gens qui assument alle on va on va
ouvrir un chapitre sur la l'hypothèse de
LR au gouvernement et on va peut-être
enterrer le l'hypothèse tout de suite
avec vous Stéphan Z tiens déjà pour
commencer est-ce que les électeurs de LR
souhaitent que ce parti voilà rentre au
gouvernement d'une certaine façon alors
oui oui il al oui les électeurs de ceux
qu'il restent pardon des électeurs der
ils sont de moins en moins nombreux
hélas pour eux depuis la première
élection d'Emmanuel Macron évidemment
oui ils souhaitent ardemment que leurs
idées que leur parti soi représenté au
sein d'un gouvernid leur parti c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose alors ils
souhaitent ils considèent aussi en
partie que leurs idées sont déjà au
gouvernement mais on a bien vu aussi une
sorte de radicalisation à la fois de la
direction et des députés à l'air lors du
projet de loi de des débat des débats
pardon sur le projet de loi
d'immigration l'électorat à droite c'est
aussi un petit peu
radicalisé rejoindre un gouvernement
d'un président de la République qui
s'appelle emmanu Emmanuel Macron
pourquoi pas mais à condition aussi que
ce gouvernement soit un gouvernement
ouvertement de droite voire de droite du
notamment sur les sujets régaliens donc
oui ils ont envie que leurs idées soient
là mais ils ne souhaitent pas que ce
soit de simple ralliment au cas par cas
parce que ça les ralliments au cas par
cas on les connaît depuis 2017 oui
rentrer au gouvernement d'accord mais du
point de vue de cette de ce petit
segment de l'électorat ça signifierait
selon lui aussi un vrai contrat de
gouvernement avec des vraies idées de
droit totalement assumé parce que de
toute façon Emmanuel Macron et le
gouvernement de Gabriel Atal ne seront
jamais prêts à assumer en tout cas
publiquement je je reprends ce que ce
que vient de dire Jean-Pierre rafarin
les dirigeants de l' ils ont aujourd'hui
60 ans à peu près donc c'est maintenant
qu'ils doivent s'afficher comme un parti
de gouvernement parce que Leino
autrement ils n'existeront pas dans les
élections ils seront marginaux comme ils
l'ont été lors de la dernière
présidentielle l'argument de Jean-Pierre
affarin est très pragmatique en effet 60
ans il est temps d'y aller parce que
sinon après ça sera trop tard je crois
que c'est un argument un peu court euh
et que comme ça vient d'être dit euh
s'il y avait une entrée de LR dans le
gouvernement ça ne pourrait se faire
qu'autour d'une forme de contrat de
gouvernement et pour l'instant d'après
ce que l'on sait aussi bien du côté du
gouvernement que de LR il n'en est pas
question c'est une hypothèse qui a
jamais été évoquée non non je ne crois
pas c'est pas une hypothèse qui est
évoquée la direction de LR de manière
claire n'est pas favorable à ce type
d'accord de gouvernement ou alors ça
serait il demanderait mais leur position
est même très minoritaire il demandera à
la majorité actuelle de se rallier
complètement à leur pro programme on l'a
vu d'ailleurs on a vu cette tentation
lors du projet de loi immigration c'est
à prendre ou à laisser donc il est assez
peu probable que l'on arrive à une
alliance de ce type il peut y avoir tel
ou tel ralliment individuel mais
j'allais dire ça se fait de manière
régulière depuis 2017 ça n'est pas très
nouveau les raliments individuels nouau
ou si si on regarde tout simplement la
composition de l'Assemblée nationale
cette hypothèse de Jean-Pierre afarin
elle a du sens ou pas d'après moi pour
moi il y a deux problèmes de moment le
premier c'est de ne pas avoir choisi
d'être un parti en alliance avec la
majorité hein parce qu'il faut pas
oublier qu'il y a eu une déclaration de
groupe qui a été déposée à l'Assemblée
nationale comme quoi LR est un parti
d'opposition et on a loupé en quelque
sorte le moment ouvert par Nicolas
Sarkozi dans l'entre deux tour en disant
leslr devrait faire partie d'un contrat
de coalition donc pour moi le le moment
n'est pas choisi là où c'était utile et
deuxème problème de moment les
européennes on est quand même à l'aube
d'un scrutin pour lequel la majorité
n'est pas particulièrement en odeur de
sainteté et on sait aussi que euh faire
coalition aujourd'hui pour les LR ça
n'est pas forcément la meilleure des
solutions sachant qu'ils ont réussi plus
ou moins l'idée d'avoir une identité sur
le débat de l'immigration qui est
centrale en matière européenne donc je
ne suis pas sûr que ça soit complètement
dans l'intérêt des LR à quelques mois de
cette élection d'entrer au gouvernement
et encore une fois d'entrer en ordre de
marche parce que comme on l'a dit il
faudrait que ce soit l'ELR qui décide
des personnalités qui entrent au
gouvernement et non pas l' des prises de
guerre dont on entend régulièrement
parler char ça fait ça fait deux fois
vous me lancez des thèmes que j'ai prévu
plus tard le vote de confiance et les
élections européenne mais c'est pas
grave et si au contraire moi mon job
c'est de m'adapter à ça mais je voudrais
d'abord qu'on qu'on ouvre un chapitre
sur ce que pourrait être les réforme
prioritaire de de Gabriel Atal mais pour
ça Mathieu il faut peut-être essayer de
définir ce que sont les convictions du
nouveau Premier ministre et pour être
honnête c'est sans doute encore un peu
tôt pour dresser un portrait idéologique
du plus jeune premier ministre de la 5e
République mais tentons une première
hypothèse l'atalisme est un macronisme
alors vous allez dire ça nous renseigne
pas beaucoup ça nous a pas beaucoup sur
sur les convictions on rappelle que
Gabriel Atal a été engagé dans sa prime
jeunesse au Parti socialiste où il a
fait la campagne en tout cas il a adhéré
pour voter pour sonen royale qu'il a
fait ses classes auprès de marisoltouren
comme député puis comme comme comme
ministre et qui fait partie de ces gens
de gauche qui ont rejoint Emmanuel
Macron l'heure était alors au des
passements des clivages vous savez le
fameux en même temps et de cette époque
je pense que le premier ministre a
surtout retenu l'efficacité le
pragmatisme qui était un peu les deux
mamelles du macronisme si j'ose dire
qu'il a su mettre en application
notamment lors de son passage au
ministère de de l'éducation oui mais
voilà le macronisme il a sérieusement
dévié avec le temps et obéissant la
célèbre formule de François miteran
selon lequel toute personne se disant ni
de gauche ni de droite finissait
irrémédiablement par mener une politique
ni de gauche GAE ni de gauche et Gabriel
Atal de ce point de vue n'échappe pas à
la règle ces décision rue de Grenel on
en a parlé sur la BAA sur rétablissement
de l'autorité du professeur ou encore
sur l'uniforme par exemple on on fait
aujourd'hui la coqueluche de la droite
ce qui nous amène à une deuxème hypoè al
la deuxième hypothèse et siatalisme
était plutôt un sarkoisme j'y pensais
hier comme beaucoup en entendant le
Premier ministre lors de son premier
déplacement dans le Pas de calis rendre
hommage à cette France laborieuse qui
travaille qui se lève tôt quelques
heures auparavant dans la cour de hôtel
Matignon au moment de la passation de
pouvoir il a déclaré sa flamme au aux
classes moyennes qui travaille qui
finance son service public et notre
modèle social tous ces Français qui
parfois ne s'y retrouvent plus disait-il
qui se lèvent tôt enfin décidément he
qui se lèvent tous les matins pour aller
travailler et qu'on entend pas souvent
vous avez vu son accent mis sur
l'autorité sur la sécurité tiens dès cet
après-midi un déplacement par jour tout
ça fait penser à la méthode Sarco com on
disait la méthode Sarco de 2007 he la
promesse de dire et de faire les choses
sans tabou d'ailleurs je précise
d'ailleurs que les deux hommes Sarkozi
et Gabriel ne se ne se connaissaient pas
ils se sont rencontrés pour la première
fois il y a 4 mois ils ont déjeuné
ensemble ça s'est plutôt très bien passé
donc là on a fait deux hypothèses il y
en a une troisième oui et si l'atalisme
était un natalisme alors encore en
devenir certes mais dont on devine au
moins les ressorts à défaut de la
matrice un flair pour humerair du temps
une capacité à trancher une rapidité
d'exécution un AR métriser du faire
savoir et puis une courtoisie
républicaine une forme de de qualité
d'écoute bref une méthode plutôt qu'un
cathéchist
aujourd'hui au service du président mais
qui sait peut-être demain au service de
ses propres ambitions Pascal Piron je je
vous imagine curieux de savoir si il y a
un natalisme différent du macronisme
oui oui oui oui on je serait très
attentif dans les mois qui viennent pour
percevoir cet éventuel détachement qui
est inéluctable qui est
inéluctable de Gabriel Atal de la
matrice qui est la sienne qui est pas
celle du Parti socialiste parce qu'il
était tout jeune bon voilà euh mais qui
est celle du macronisme hein comment il
va se détacher pourquoi vous dites c'est
inéluctable c'est inéluctable parce que
d'abord la dérive au meilleur sens du
terme d'un Premier ministre par rapport
au président qui l'a nommé et toujours
j'all souvenez-vous du duo mitéran
Fabius vous voyez voilà hein bon on a
bien vu que Fabius avait besoin
d'exister par lui-même souvenons-nous du
duo Chaban Pompidou Chaban va peu à peu
exister par lui-même au point d'ailleurs
d'exaspérer le président Pompidou et
d'être licencié donc euh je crois que
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est inscrit
dans la fonction même de Premier
ministre il est jeune le président ne se
représentera pas et donc il y a un après
Macron qu'il va qui va venir très vite
et il est maintenant ce il n'était pas
jusqu'à maintenant là-dedans mais il est
maintenant dans une phase de
construction d'une cré crédibilité
présidentielle he Gabri bien sûr et il
est dans la course à la
présidentiabilité si on peut oser ce
néologisme au côté et bien voilà
d'Édouard
Philippe de et d'autres candidat
potentiel comme Bruno Le Maire ou
géralde Darmanin hein ça y est la course
est lancée et lui il a un avantage c'est
de venir du cœur de la macronie et de ne
pas avoir si vous voulez d'être un homme
po
qui rappelle le Macron de la grande
période celle de 2017 on se disait ah
mon Dieu ça va être une nouveauté
radicale la révolution comme il le
disait dans son dans dans dans son
bouquin donc il a sur la ligne de départ
quelques avantages ça n'est pas un
technocrate non plus comme l'est par
exemple Édouard Philippe ou Bruno Le
Maire voyez il peut peu à peu cultiver
sa différence vous parliez de la
présidentiabilité de Gabriel hatal euh
ce ce sondage réalisé hier la question
pensez-vous que ces personnalités
seraient de bons candidats pour
représenter la majorité à la
présidentielle de 2027 alors évidemment
c'est dans longtemps mais bon derrière
Édouard Philippe on trouve Gabriel Atal
et il progresse c'est ça que je trouve
fascinant de 17 points en 4 mois à peine
Stéphan ZS que c'est fulgurant est-ce
que vous avez souvenir d'une progression
aussi aussi rapide dans une
présidentiabilité justement non non moi
je nai pas souvenir d'une telle
progression mais elle s'explique aussi
en tout cas par sa par son caractère
massif par le fait que on parle de
quelqu'un qui il y a quelques mois
encore n'était pas très connu et qui est
devenu d'un coup très connu et et ça
c'est grâce à son talent très populaire
est-ce que Macron avait avait avait
avait bénéficié comme ça d'une telle
fulgurance dans sa présidentiabilité non
ça avait été beaucoup plus long parce
que d'abord Emmanuel Macron au début
n'était que secrétaire général adjoint
de l'élsée il avait pris Bery qui était
évidemment un un un ministère de de
poids mais sa présidentiabilité il
l'avait travaillé au jour le jour mois
après mois tout ça avait pris beaucoup
de temps il l'avait fait avec énormément
d'efficacité point d'être élu évidemment
il avait aussi bénéficié des de l'impact
de l'affaire Fillon mais mais c'est
beaucoup plus fulgurant dans le cas
d'Emmanuel de pardon de Gabriel Atal et
là encore vous en parliez à l'instant
sur ce qu'il représente il a un énorme
avantage sur ses prédécesseurs c'est
qu'il arrive connu et populaire ou ce
n'est pas c'était pas les cas des autres
Édouard Philippe a mis des mois'est des
années à devenir populair cont c'est les
autres on peut dire que alors c'est
peut-être aussi d'ailleurs quand Gabriel
dit je dois tout au président de la
République c'est ça y revient mais c'est
quand même Emmanuel Macron qui avait
entre guillemets
créer le le le poids politique les
personnalités politiques d'un d'un édard
Philippe d'un Jean Castex même si c'est
un autre registre là ce n'est pas le cas
c'est pas le cas et lui arrive avec déjà
une certaine épaisseur politique récente
bien sûr mais une vraie épaisseur
politique ce qui en fait dès le jour de
sa nomination quelque part le chef
incontesté de la majorité c'est lui qui
va mener on en parlera peut-être tout à
l'heure la bataille électorale dans le C
des élections européenne et rien que ça
il est à dououbé et il a il prend déjà
un poids politique incontournable ce
n'était pas le cas des autres entendait
parler du des binômes euh exécutifs et
effectivement je me souviens de Laurent
Fabius je crois que c'est septembre 84
j'ai recherché ça quand il dit c'est une
émission politique avec Alain duamel qui
l'interview lui c'est lui moi c'est moi
on parlant de de François mitteran
donc c'est la comparaison elle est
évidente puisque c'était auparavant le
plus jeune premier ministre de la 5e
République à charine Bina la la
difficulté pour pour Gabriel Atal c'est
de réussir à effectivement maîtriser
cette dérive est-ce qu'il peut le faire
à travers les textes puisque le le but
de ce chapitre c'est de voir sur quelle
réforme il va aller est-ce que il peut
le faire grâce aux réformes qu'il va
engager dans les prochains mois vous
nous disiez tout à l'heure elles vont
être potentiellement moins cvantes que
celles qu' a dû porter Elisabeth borne
oui il peut le faire à travers les
textes bien sûr il peut il peut imprimer
sa marque à travers un programme de
gouvernement néanmoins c'est juste quand
même en terme de délai pour imprimer sa
marque et pour arriver à tuer le père
tout en étant sous son ascendance en à
peine ans si ce n'est peut-être moins
avec ce fameux scrtin des europénes donc
je crois que c'est peut-être inéluctable
de tuer le père mais on est quand même
dans une configuration comme il l'a dit
il lui doit beaucoup et donc c'est
encore un peu tôt pour lui pour savoir
aussi quelle identité il va pouvoir
construire et je crois nécessairement
que les textes qu'il devra défendre
dépendront aussi de la couleur du
président de la République donc c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est que on a à
faire à une personnalité qui se démarque
déjà mais pour autant politiquement on a
du mal à connaître comme vous disiez
quel atalisme et surtout sur quel texte
il va pouvoir imprimer quelque chose
est-ce qu'il va continuer à s'engager
sur l'école on on a beaucoup de
questions autour de ce qu'il va vouloir
engager dans les années à venir et
surtout au niveau parlementaire mais
déjà en étant nommé à Matignon il y a ce
mot qui apparaît latalisme on l'avait
jamais prononcé sur ce plateau je suis
pas sûr qu'il a besoin d'un texte pour
s'imposer pour construire une
personnalité politique pas le souvenir
que les Français attribuent à Édouard
Philippe un texte il y a les
circonstances qui font le style qui fait
aussi et on sait que Édouard Philippe
notamment le regain de popularité il là
dans cet exercice qui étit compliqué de
la gestion du covid où il avait fait
preuve d'une forme de de transparence
face aux Français et d'une gestion qui
avait l'air d'être de bon sens j'allais
dire de de gentilhomme presque mais mais
c'est donc les circonstances révèlent
aussi un homme à l'épreuve du pouvoir
par ailleurs sur le fond il y a quand
même quelque chose bizarre Emmanuel
Macron promet un rendez-vous avec la
nation un réarmement civique enfin bref
on a on a on a l'impression que la
feuille de route elle va être donnée par
le président le problème c'est que
visiblement le discours de politique
générale aur a lieu avant la feuille de
route présidentielle donc de toute façon
on va avoir un Premier ministre qui ne
serait-ce que dans son discours
politique général soit va retenir sa
plume soit ce sera fait dicter son
discours mais en tout cas il est obligé
d'être dans la ligne que que que que que
sera enfin que que défendra Emmanuel
Macron quelques jours plus tard puisque
le le le grand discours de d'Emmanuel
Macron doit être prononcé à la
mi-janvier ce alors j'allais dire brfer
c'est peut-être un peu fort mais cette
recherche de de d'autonomie elle se joue
déjà quand le Premier ministre structure
son cabinet le choix du directeur de
cabinet dans le le choix des ministres
là qui vont être nommés dans les
prochains jours Charl je je crois qu'il
faut pas qu'on nette que nous sommes
encore dans le système de la 5e
République qui est profondément décrié
mais qui laisse très peu de surface
politique euh alors il a de la surface
constitutionnelle mais politiquement il
existe très peu dans un système
majoritaire comme le nôtre et euh qui
plus est aujourd'hui euh il faut pas
oublier encore une nouvelle citation de
François mitteran à propos de Laurent
Fabius lorsqu'il parlait du jeune
premier ministre que j'ai donné à la
France on est un peu dans ça aussi pour
Emmanuel Macron c'estm dire que tous les
atouts de Gabriel hatal sont sûrement
pensés pour lui revenir un petit peu
donc la surface politique qu'il a le
discours de politique générale qu'il a
on est un petit peu dans l'écueil de
Jacques chabandmoise justement
c'est-à-dire que lui-même avait voulu
créer son propre style et ça lui a coûté
sa place donc je crois nécessairement
que Gabriel Attal n'est pas encore dans
le temps de l'autonomie surtout voilà
dans les quelques jours qui séparent
Emmanuel Macron sa grande annonce alors
je je vais reprendre le baromètre de
confiance et me tourner vers vous zumse
parce que il démarre on l'a dit 56 % de
confiance c'est relativement élevé et
c'est intéressant regarde par
sympathisant politique euh il est à
presque à la moitié 49 % chez LFI 55 %
de confiance au sein des syatisants
socialistes 58 % chez les écologistes 96
% chez Renaissance 62 % au sein du parti
LR et le chiffre le plus bas c'est au
rassemblement national 40 % est-ce que
il élargit de nouveau le le en même
temps macroniste vous voyez ce que je
veux dire en tout cas il en bénéficie
lui si si on prend le spectre finalement
du du profil des gens qui ont voté pour
Emmanuel Macron au premier tour en 2017
et aussi en partie en 2022 il y avait
des gens rappelez-vous en 2017 il y a
plus de gens de gauche que de droite qui
votent pour Emmanuel Macron au premier
tour pourtant la politique menée depuis
n'a pas véritablement été une politique
de
centre-gauche Gabriel Atal et c'est ce
qui fait sa singularité aujourd'hui il
séduit encore des segments important de
cet électorat modéré centre gauche
centre droit mais également aussi à
droite là encore en tant que ministre de
l'éducation nationale il il a été très
explicite en tout cas en terme d'annonce
sur la restauration de l'autorité dans
le cadre de l'école et ça c'est
typiquement le type de mesure ou de
déclaration qui plaisent à un électorat
souvent âgé mais en tout cas et souvent
de droite pas forcément par par parce
que âgé mais c'est
évidemment auprès des de l'électorat de
droite qu'on retrouve le plus de seigor
et ça ça lui bénéficie et ça il n'y a
pas de raison qu'il s'effondre en terme
de popularité dans les semaines qui
viennent en tout cas parce que il a
réussi là encore et c'est une belle
performance qu'il faut souligner et donc
une certaine réussite pour le président
de la République en tout cas une bonne
surprise de la part du président de la
République auprès de ces électorats là
de finalement nommer à matigon quelqu'un
qui qui plaît qui plaît d'emblé
j'insiste les gens ne sont pas en train
de se dire j'attends de voir il
bénéficie d' d'ors et déjà d'un capital
sympathie ça durera ce que ça durera
mais c'est un réel avantage une réelle
différence par rapport à ses
prédécesseurs notamment quand on sait
que dans 5 mois il y a les élections
européennes Pascal per un mot sur sa sa
feuille de route si vous deviez
parierier sur une réforme à la hatale
dans les dans dans les prochaines
semaines ou prochain mois il il y a des
réformes il y a des textes de loi qui
sont déjà prévus évidemment au
calendrier parlementaire mais alors je
je crois que la question de l'éducation
que le président lui-même a mis à
l'agenda en disant que ça allait être
une des questions essentielles du second
quinquena le fait qu'il n'est passé que
6 mois il a éveiller des espoirs
phénoménaux hein phénoménaux en 6 mois
mais il n'a passé tout même que 6 mois
Rud
grenelation nationale voilà 5 mois et 20
jours donc ça n'est pas beaucoup et il a
agi essentiellement d'ailleurs ce qui
montre que la réforme ne passe pas
forcément par de grands projets de loi
il agit en effet par la voie
réglementaire et on peut faire des
choses on peut déplacer les ligne en
effet par la voie réglementaire ça va ça
lui a donné certainement des idées des
idées pour la suite pour échapper au
milestom de l'assemblée nationalein de
moins jouer en effet voilà le recours au
493 et cette espèce
d'hystérie qui se déroule régulièrement
autour du recours à l'article 49 alinéa
3 donc je crois que la question de
l'éducation va être essentielle et puis
bien sûr il va jouer ou tenter de jouer
si le président en est d'accord sur le
fait qu'il a acquis une crédibilité sur
le terrain régalien euh sécurité
immigration immigration toute une partie
du travail est fait sur la sécurité on
sent bien les derniers chiffres sur la
sécurité sont ex
sont extrêmement Mauvaisin donc là aussi
il va falloir faire autre chose que des
visites dans les commissariats il va
falloir sur la la longue période montrer
que on peut avoir une capacité des
politiques publiques capable de de de
freiner cette montée cette montée de
l'insécurité donc je crois que là-dessus
il y a un terrain sur lequel mais c'est
un terrain qui joue avant tout à droite
on a vu que sa structure de popularité
est très centrale oui très centr été
assez surpris par les 58 % de
sympathisantsolog son a un électeur sur
deux ou un sympathtisant sur deux de la
France insoumise quiit confience vous
rendez compte c'est assez loin du
discours vément de de par exemple de
Mathilde Panau hein
donc il faut aussi qu'ilenvoie quelques
signau à la gauche il va être en fait le
chef d'orchestre de la campagne des
européennes donc là-dessus il va pouvoir
rallier certainement une partie des
électeurs et puis à la thématique en
effet du travail et on verra ce qu'il
est capable de proposer sur le terrain
du travail je crois qu'il a déjà dans
les tuyaux une rencontre qui est prévue
avec les forces sociales c'est ce qu'il
avait annoncé les élections européennes
on y vient maintenant et Tam tranui peut
nous rejoindre tout de suite sur ce
plateau puisque bonsoir Tam bienvenue
bonsoir ça fait partie des missions du
nouveau Premier ministre mener la
campagne des élections européennes voilà
Premier ministre et tête de liste par
procuration on sent bien l'idée c'est
que le soldat Gabriel hatal Vienne
sauver des élections européennes qui
s'annonce mal même si bon un sondage 5
mois avant ça ne veut rien dire sur les
résultats finals ça veut dire quand même
quelque chose sur la situation politique
aujourd'hui et maintenant or les
derniers sondages laissent apparaître le
rassemblement national en tête Jordane
bardala a crédité d'autour de 30 % des
intentions de vote et l'attelage
Renaissance modem horizon et loin
derrière 10 points derrière or et bien
Gabriel hatal c'est l'ennemi préféré de
Jordan Bardella dans les médias où il a
pu l'affronter à six reprises et où
l'affiche a généralement bien fonctionné
niveau audience notamment 34 ans côté
Gabriel Attal 28 ans pour la tête de
liste rassemblement national voilà le
choc des générations qui promet audace
et mouvement audace et mouvement ce sont
les mots employés hier par Gabriel hatal
on n'est jamais mieux servi que par
soi-même pour essayer de mobiliser sur
une élection la participation est
traditionnellement faible le roman ent
gouvernemental à d'évidence donc des
ambitions électorales pourquoi cette
élection est aussi importante pour le
président de la République d'abord parce
que l'Europe et bien c'est l'identité
d'Emmanuel Macron rappelez-vous l'hyne à
la joie lorsqu'Emmanuel Macron entre
seul face à la pyramide du Louvre lors
de sa victoire de 2017 ou encore le
discours de la Sorbonne sur l'Europe et
encore ne l'a-t-il pas rappelé vendredi
dernier lors de l'hommage national rendu
à Jacques delur
écoutez ce chemin son chemin se poursuit
un chemin difficile chemin de crête qui
s'éloigne des facilités et des faux
semblants toujours en déséquilibre et
qui tient la nation et l'Europe la force
économique et la justice
sociale le réel et l'idéal
ensemble enfin
réconcilié voilà donc les obsèes d'un
grand Européen qui se transformme
lanement de campagne une façon de rendre
hommage à l'autre mais surtout pour
parler de soi et vu que l'Europe c'est
l'ADN d'Emmanuel Macron il paraît donc
logique d'aller chercher son clone dans
la personne de Gabriel Atal et élection
importante évidemment parce qu'elle se
situe à mi mandat c'est la seule
échéance électorale majeure d'ici 2027
une victoire du rassemblement national
sonnerait comme une un sombre
avertissement pour Emmanuel Macron que
l'on imagine alors paralysé pour la
suite pour la fin de son mandat et ce
alors qu'il ne peut pas se représenter
bien sûr en 2027 et pour incarner le il
choisit quelqu'un qui ne braque ni le
centre gauche sa famille politique
initiale ni la droite qu' apprécie
depuis ses sorties sur laaba l'autorité
à l'école et l'autorité tout court de
quoi grappiller des voix à François
Xavier bami et à Raphaël gluxman
pressenti comme tête de liste LR et
socialiste ceux qui ont le plus à
craindre finalement avec l'arrivée de
Gabriel Atal le problème reste bien sûr
ce que vous disiez au début être Premier
ministre ça abîme ce n'est pas facile on
n'est pas populaire éternellement bien
au contraire Emmanuel Macron espère que
ça durera au moins 5 mois merci beaucoup
Tam je me tourne je me tourne vers vous
Stéphane zumseek ce ce duel Atal
bardellaa on en prend pour combien de
décennies 40 ans ils sont 34 et 28 donc
si on fait les calculs ils seront ils
seront encore là dans 40 ans oui
peut-être il y a forcément quelqu'un qui
laissera les plumes dans dans dans 5
mois évidemment mais là encore le choix
de Gabriel Atal pour mener alors il ne
sera pas têre de liste évidemment mais
en tout cas pour en tant que chef de la
majorité et Premier ministre pour mener
la la bataille électorale il est assez
judicieux de la part du président de la
République parce que là encore
ellisabeth borne qui n'a pas démérité en
tant que Premier ministre évidemment
mais qui n'a fait qu'appliquer ce que le
président de la République lui demandé
d'appliquer était était en partie
démonétisé au au sein de auprès en tout
cas de des députés des parlementaires de
ce bloc de ce bloc présidentiel donc
c'est plutôt un bon choix mais TER en
parler aussi il y a il y a deux enjeux
hein c'est ok ce duel à distance entre
les deux parce que ça restera un duel à
distance entre Jordan bardellaa et le
Premier ministre parce que il y a pas de
porosité électorale entre ces deux
forces politiques on n'hésite pas entre
le rassemblement national et la
République en marche en Renaissance
pardon en revanche effectivement il y a
toujours des voix siphoné auprès des LR
et il y a quand même une nouvelle menace
pour la macronie c'est que pour la
première fois000 depuis 2017 on sent
pointre une sorte d'espoir de
reconstitution d'un pôle d'attraction au
centre gauche c'était pas le cas hein le
PS était moribon euh la liste gluxman la
liste PS elle pourrait être très
dangereuse parce que pour le coup là
c'est elle qui pourrait siffonner en
partie en partie seulement évidemment
une liste
Renaissance et le spectre pour le
président de la République c'est une
déroute électorale le la question n'est
pas de savoir qui arrivera en tête même
si évidemment en 5 mois il va se passer
plein de choses évidemment que la liste
du rassemblement national de Jordan
Bardella est d'ors et déjà la grande
favorite de ce scrutin mais imaginez que
la liste de la macronie finisse sous les
20 % plus près des 15 % que des 20 %
mais qu'est-ce que vous faites après
vous êtes à mi mandat c'est la seule
élection à portée nationale que fait
Emmanuel Macron pour maintenir son
autorité et sa
parole
poser à Pascal per parce que Tam nous
disant Emmanuel Macron sera paralysé si
s'il y a effectivement une défaite
électoral aux européennes jusqu'à
présent les élections européennes ont
pas provoqué un tel séisme pour l'action
présidentielle voyez ce que je veux dire
oui mais mais là il faut faire très très
attention à ce qui va se passer parce
que on peut avoir un phénomène
d'envoler c'est ça à quoi on assiste
d'ailleurs dans les sondages d'opinion
d'envoler du rassemblement national qui
annonce une très profonde redistribution
des cartes pour la prochaine pour la
prochaine présidentielle et on peut
avoir comment dire un tassement des
forces de la majorité qui annonce au
fond l'évanouissement la quasi
disparition d'un courant macroniste au
fond le macronisme joue son avenir
politique si vous voulez s'il y a une
rebipolarisation gauche- droite
traditionnelle avec une liste menée par
Raphaël gluxman qui pour l'instant est
la troisième liste c'est une bonne
position hein d'être en 3è liste quand
on veut chahuter un peu l'ordre
d'arrivée s'il y a une robipolarisation
si véritablement peu à peu la fonte des
neiges macronistes commence avec et et
va renforcer la liste Luxman d'un côté
une liste bami éventuellement de l'autre
ça veut dire que le macronisme n'a plus
d'avenir et que le macronisme et ceux
qui se revendiquent peuvent
éventuellement disparaître du paysage
donc c'est c'est extrêmement important
ce qui va se jouer et à cet égard les
européennes de juin prochain ne sont pas
des européennes comme les autres alors
vous nous dites il y a pas de porosité
entre les électorats rassemblement
national et Renaissance mais alors quand
même quand on entend Gabriel hatal cet
après-midi lors de cette visite au au
commissariat de d'Ermont auonne dans le
valdoise on a vraiment l'impression qui
s'adresse quand même aux électeurs du
rassemblement national écoutez à hermont
comme
partout en France vivent des Français
qui
aspirent à l'ordre et à la
tranquillité français qui travaillent
qui ne manqu jamais à leur
responsabilité des
Français quel que soit leur activité au
quotidien mais qui en tout cas aspire à
pouvoir vivre tranquillement et
paisiblement dans notre pays et je le
dis il n'y a pas de sécurité sans nos
policiers il n'y a pas d'ordre
républicain sans notre colisse je suis
pas psychologue mais l'analyse du du
langage corporel de Gérald daranin il y
aurait il y aurait un sujet ou une
émission à faire autour de ça mais c'est
pas notre notre thème du jour jeais
terminer sur le le vote de confiance
parce que j'essaie de tenir les
promesses on l'a évoqué mais très
rapidement tout à l'heure an Charlen
beina elle est effectivement un vot de
confiance qui est réclamé on va dire par
la gauche on a entendu LFI on part tout
à l'heure mais Olivier fort ou fambien
Roussel l'ont aussi demander il y a une
probabilité quoi ultra faible que que
Gabriel soumette il y a pas d'obligation
d'abord c'est quoi une tradition
républicaine alors en réalité il y a une
obligation constitutionnelle qui a
toujours été enfin en tout cas depuis 66
par George pontpidou interprété comme
une faculté donc aujourd'hui nos
gouvernants ont plutôt le sentiment que
c'est à eux de décider si oui ou non ils
soumettent la confiance Elisabeth born
ne l'ayant pas fait on voit pas trop
pourquoi Gabriel Atal tenterait cette
épreuve du feu bien que normalement la
question de confiance mobilise votre
majorité donc si sa majorité est bien en
rang derrière lui il devrait pas y avoir
de problème mais je ne vois pas en effet
solliciter cette confiance euh néanmoins
ça veut dire quelque chose aussi c'est
rare que sous la 5e République il n'y
ait pas ensuite d'autres occasions
d'être présenté à la confiance de
l'Assemblée nationale les 493 pour ne
pas les citer mais aussi d'autres
déclarations de politique générale sur
lesquels et bien il est bon quand même
de tenter de coaliser autour de lui donc
a priori si Gabriel hatal dure après les
élections européenn il aura de toute
façon à se confronter à la coalition de
sa majorité n'oublions pas quand même
que nous avons vu émerger à la fin de
l'année 2023 peut-être des frondeurs au
sein de de la majorité alors pas à ce
titre là mais on a une majorité de plus
en plus dissipé et je crois que son rôle
à l'Assemblée nationale ça sera avant
tout de jouer le en même temps
c'est-à-dire de prouver que la coalition
Renaissance non seulement peut gagner un
scrutin mais peut ensuite retrouver
toute sa cohésion autour de sa personne
donc il ne peut pas continuer tout seul
il faut qu'il montre qu'il est le leader
de sa majorité et ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose de difficile à faire oui
od C mouvements TR les a rappelé tout à
l'heure c'était les les mots utilisés
par Gabriel Atal lors de la passation de
pouvoir avec Élisabeth B Mathieu B soyez
audacieux Monsieur le Premier Ministre
soumettez-vous au vote de confiance ça
serait
rock je suis pas certain qui qui qui
souhait prendre ce risque effectivement
parce il y a trop de coup à prendre
avant même d'avoir démarré vous pouvez
engager un rapport de force un bras de
fer une fois que vous êtes posé mais en
faire la première a ça serait très très
audacieux pour le coup merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat et et à bientôt sur sur public
c'est là